Star Wars is one of the most successful film series in history.
As a kid, I remember the epic battles between Luke Skywalker and Darth Vader.
In fact, today, I still enjoy bringing my own kids to the most recent Star Wars
film. The cinematography, the special effects, and the storyline have captured
generations.
Star Wars also introduced the West to the worldview known as pantheism.
As
we have seen, naturalism is the worldview that says only physical things exist and
there are no supernatural forces.
By contrast, pantheism is the worldview that says all is divine and there's no
distinction between creator and creation.
Like naturalism, pantheism offers answers to our four big worldview questions.
The first question is, what is real?
Well on pantheism, all is divine.
God is not a personal being whom we know, but is inseparable from the universe.
God is more like a cosmic energy that pervades all things.
Sound familiar? This is like the force in Star Wars.
In essence, all is one. Our second question is, what is man?
Well if God is one with the universe and all is divine, then by necessity, man
is divine. Man is God. Pantheists will sometimes refer to human beings
as gods or goddesses in embryo. So rather than seeing human beings as
uniquely created in the image of God but broken by sin, pantheists see human beings
as essentially good and divine.
Our third worldview question is what happens at death?
The goal of mankind on pantheism is to achieve enlightenment and to escape the
cycle of reincarnation. And this is accomplished through practices such as
channeling, meditation, and yoga.
And then like a drop falling into a river, we achieve enlightenment and become
absorbed into the oneness of the universe.
The fourth worldview question is, what is the basis for right and wrong?
Since on pantheism all is one, distinctions are ultimately artificial.
There is no distinction between creator and creation, between God and man,
between right and wrong. Morality is an illusion.
Since good and evil don't exist ultimately morality is
relative.
Like naturalism, pantheism is nothing new.
Some of the ideas we see in the Star Wars films have their roots in ancient Eastern
religions such as Hinduism and Buddhism.
In fact, Paul likely addressed some pantheists in his speech at Mars Hill
as recorded in Acts chapter 17.
Pantheism is not new, but it is in direct conflict and contrast with the Christian
worldview. The biggest question is, can it adequately capture reality as we know it
and experience it?